liam hemsworth wants to have a whole
litter of kids with Miley Cyrus yep a
whole litter the actor covers GQ
Australia's May June issue and when the
mag ghastly him about starting a family
with his new bride
he explained quote one day once we don't
have so many dogs you couldn't bring a
baby into our house right now but one
day we'll know when it's right
but right now not for the time being and
he's not kidding you guys they have
seven dogs two pigs horses several cats
it's basically like a straight-up
freaking farm over there but Liam
revealed he hopes that they do have a
ton of babies in the future in fact he
said quote ten fifteen maybe twenty um
does Miley know about this plan because
this sounds um a painful and B like
chaos but anyway kids may not be in the
immediate plan for Miley and Liam but
they've already been through a lot of
life changes over the last year which he
admits was quote pretty hectic their
house was actually destroyed in the
California wildfires and Liam explains
that he got the call from Miley in the
middle of the night she actually found
out the news from a friend he said quote
that was pretty gut-wrenching it was
actually real and it's just a hard hard
thing to come to terms with he also
opened up about losing their house
overnight and all the possessions that
they lost but there was one in
particular that he was extra upset about
he said the one thing I wish I did grab
was this Rolex that Lionsgate had given
me as a present
after the first Hunger Games film came
out I always imagined giving it to my
first son or something but who needs a
Rolex when you have a love like Miley
and Liam they actually ended up tying
the knot just a month later and Liam
revealed 2gq just how this devastating
experience actually made them realize
there was no reason to wait to say I do
he said quote going through something
this emotional with someone it brings
you closer and we felt like we'd lost a
big part of our lives so we wanted to
make a new part of our lives it was
going to happen eventually but I think
this just sped it up a little bit et was
with Liam shortly after the lovebirds
made Italy
and he could not help but gush over his
leading lady
to be wife husband and wife it's the
best it's the best um you know I feel so
lucky to be with someone like her yeah
it's very very very lucky just a few
weeks later Maile was on wifey duty when
Liam got sick and he couldn't attend the
premiere of his romantic comedy isn't it
romantic
Liam's feeling good he has to you know
rest up but he loves this film he's so
proud of it and I really wanted to be
able to represent it Ram we heard
hospitalized what's wrong is he okay
yeah he'll be okay you know just you
needed to take care of himself and
getting healthy he's more important than
anything else so I'm here to represent I
had my dress already and I couldn't let
it go to waste so guys I've said it once
I'll say it again I'll say it a thousand
million times I'll shout it from the
rooftops
I stand for these two they are seriously
the cutest and of course we'll be here
to keep you up to date on all things
Miley and Liam so be sure to keep it
locked on et until next time I'm Hallie
Stephens bye for now
[Music]